making Europe the first carbon-neutral
continent by 2050 is the ultimate goal
of the new climate law that the European
Parliament has begun examining
addressing members of the parliaments
Environment Committee Swedish climates
activist Greta klumberg said the law
doesn't go far enough we don't just need
goals for 2030 or 2050 we above all need
them for 2020 and for every following
year to come
you yourselves declared that we are in
the climates and environment emergency
you said this was an existential threats
now you must prove that you mean it and
we will not be satisfied with anything
less than a science-based pathway the
climate law is a cornerstone of Europe's
Green Deal to fight climate change the
Commission's proposal would give the EU
stronger powers to bind member states to
lower co2 emission targets invest in
green technologies and protect the
environment but tough negotiations
between the European Parliament and EU
member states lie ahead leafy vestal if
a nations relations a new Sun on her
lapel rabbit a new keema not ahora los
canoes Oh Tallulah left Sadat Whoville
solution juiced juicy a plan social
select on territorial a credible
credible plan scientific forgives all
applause no see Fred absorb Brown and
hysteria
[Applause]